The features of the Internet that we
really want to make sure persist.
And I don't count on a nurse shot to do
the job here,
but these features include the fact that
when we're surfing the web that we're
actually visiting lots of different
places.
The web of 1998 and sort of through the
past 10 years or so has been one where
there's lots of baskets with eggs all
over the place.
And by just clicking on a link,
you can visit that new basket and not
even feel the burdens of the journey.
It could be in a basement in Chappaqua,
New York,
the server you're going to,
it could be Amazon,
it could be,
uh,
is somewhere in Europe,
you name it to anywhere around the
world.
That I think has been less and less so.
And part of the research,
uh,
I'm working on is to actually document
and figure out if that hypothesis is
true.
I'm actually concerned that because of
worries about things like denial of
service attacks where websites might be
brought down,
what we'll see our websites huddling
under the umbrella of just a handful of
Internet service hosting providers.
So it might feel like you're going from
one website to another when in fact all
you're doing is visiting one quarter of
the massive data banks at Amazon that
offers up commodity web hosting to the
world that puts all the eggs in one
basket,
which seems dangerous to me.
If Amazon goes down,
everything goes down,
not just your ability to one click
purchase.
I'm a mouse trap.
And uh,
it also means that there are regulatory
changes made possible so that if a
government of the world wants something
taken down or dealt with,
they only have one door to knock on.
And depending on your view of how easily
government should be able to take stuff
down,
that's either a good thing or a bad
thing.
So having a distributed web with eggs
across lots of baskets is one thing that
I hope will persist.
The other thing is I hope the web will
persist.
You know,
the number of times,
uh,
you might find yourself living your
digital life by running a browser and
typing in a link.
And then from the trap he is going from
one place to another,
uh,
visiting each site and clicking on links
and typing stuff that's starting to feel
possibly very 2005 more and more the way
in which we experience the world or
through apps.
So if you were told,
you could still use your smart phone but
you just can't load up the browser,
you can only use apps and those apps
might have a browser quietly running in
the background.
But the experience you'll get inside
that APP is so much more defined by the
APP maker.
And you know,
if you're looking at facebook and you
see the sponsored links,
you're getting importuning you to do
something.
Almost always it's bottom line,
please install this app.
Everybody wants you to install their app
and that's because that's putting you
inside the bottle of a miniature
universe that isn't necessarily
connected web like to the rest of
things.
If you see something interesting inside
an app and you want to share it,
it will be under the terms of that APP.
Whether you can email the link or
whether you can only tweet it or whether
you can do anything with it.
There's not a common url,
that bar at the top that you can just
copy and paste and share with a friend
and then that friend can see what you
see.
So as I look to the future,
really thinking about the future of the
web itself is something we we ought to
be doing.
I don't take for granted that there will
be a worldwide web the way that there
has been,
it might be much more stove piped and
feel a little bit more like 1985 with in
America,
compuserve,
prodigy,
and the source.
Okay.
You've got your apps.
Those apps in turn are there at the
sufferance of your,
uh,
mobile phone or your other platform
vendor and so much more staid
possibility.
And so much of the benefits of the
Internet have come from unusual corners
from not being so staid.
I'd hate to think,
oh,
those were the early days.
Things have matured.
Now there is a genuine worry about
security that has it no longer seems so
crazy as it probably did.
I think it did.
And say the year 2000 g maybe before you
run an APP,
someone out there should vet it,
should know who wrote it,
should have their contact information on
file.
The way that if you get into a taxi cab,
remember taxi cabs,
there'd be a an identity marker.
If you use an uber or Lyft,
they have some way of knowing who the
drivers are.
They're registered.
If that's the level of security you want
when you drive three blocks,
why wouldn't you want that for code to
which you are and trusting your most
intimate details and more and more.
I think that's what we see happening.
I don't know that that's terrible,
but it does show a general trend in the
name of security in having
intermediaries be able to more tightly
control the code that we can run,
whether it's on our device or afar,
and the content that we can see.